окупаційна держава Російська Федерація
країна терорист а-а заявила що вона
провела так звані референдуми на
окупованих нею українських землях
очевидно що це фарс - це
псевдо-референдуми і весь світ бачив Як
рахують порожні бюлетені як зганяють в
просто знищеному Маріуполі інших містах
і містечках
окупованої частини України нещасних
людей на ці так звані референдуми світу
вже відреагував але як на наш погляд
недостатньо жорстко на цей фарс і спроби
вкрасти анексувати частину українських
територій і наша політична команда буде
працювати над тим щоб відповідь світу
зокрема санкційний тиск на російську
федерацію на всіх причетних до цієї
спроби анексії наших регіонів бо більш
жорсткий і ми хочемо проанансувати що
цього тижня Петро Порошенко лідери
європейського солідарності починається в
таке велике європейське турнедо братиме
участь в низки конференції а також
відвідує фуруми де спілкуватиметься з
депутатами з політиками державними
діячами країн Європи для того щоб в
першу чергу звернути увагу на
необхідність посилення збройної
фінансової підтримки України але
по-друге так само посилити санкційний
тиск проти російської федерації яка
розуміє тільки мову сили і очевидно що
ми маємо говорити не тільки про
відповідальність Росії Яка це
організували як намагається просто так
красти українській території маємо так
само звернути увагу європейських і
світових медіа політиків на правильну
термінологію коли там пишуть що якісь
відсотки на якихось начебто референдумах
там щось проголосували це все
неправильно має називатися речі своїми
іменами ніяких референдумів не було під
дула мене навіть пістолетів в автоматів
під градами людей намагалися примусити
піти на ці ділянки дільниці ніхто нікуди
не ходив просто намалювали все це але
наш брифінг присвячений не тільки
відповідальності Росії Яка має бути
визнана країною терористом яка має бути
визнана її дією в Україні геноцидом а і
відповідальності тих колаборантів і
зрадників які На жаль співпрацюють з
окупаційною Владою власне Ми вітаємо
рішення ради нас безпеки і оборони і
рішення українських судів які заборонили
ті партії що дали оцей такий відчутний
відсоток колаборантів із радників які
багато років просували кремлівські
російські неративи в Україні і мова іде
і про опзж і про партію шарія і про
партію цю прогресивну соціалістичну там
партію і про партію мураєва ну всього
цього
підтанцьовки
кремлівської і ми вітаємо ці рішення що
партії заборонені але давайте подивимося
тепер що відбувається в реалі коли
керівництво
мажоритарної нашої команди
монобільшості слуг народу говорить що їх
найкращі тепер побратими в парламенті це
ажмідки упсж що вони там разом
конструктивно дуже працюють голосують
під голосовують будь-яке рішення
сьогодні дійсно проводиться це слуги
народу і опзж які навіть своїй базі
створили ПМЖ тепер датаку партію от вони
там дві гру- угруповання створили такі
парламенті і все підголосовують у нас
представники цих партій не тільки в
Верховній Раді а в місцевих радах де в
шаріївці там досі засідають всі ці інші
колишні регіонали вони займають керівні
посади в комітетах вони створюють якісь
нові групи і продають свої послуги Владі
і Вибачте якщо ми як країна вимагаємо
покарання не тільки для Путіна а для
всіх росіян за їх причетність до війни в
Україні то так само заборонені партії
мають бути заборонені а їх представники
не можуть сьогодні натягти на себе
вишиванку і назватися вже там іншою
партією і бігти знову в міжнародні
делегації в керівництво комітетів в
розподіли бюджетів і таке інше Вони
мають понести політичну відповідальність
морально відповідальність і власне має
бути виконана норма закону І тому
європейська Солідарність напрацювала І
реєструє сьогодні і ми Закликаємо колег
від всіх парламентських фракцій
підписатися під цим законопроектом які
ми зараз викладаємо в систему
електронного документообігу
законопроект про справжню
відповідальність заборонених партій і їх
представників І власне це законопроект
Про те що представ школі заборонених
партій не мають права створювати нові
групи очолювати
комітети І взагалі рішення суду має бути
паралельно з забороною партією про
скасування їх депутатських повноважень
якщо партія заборонена Ну як її
представник може далі представляти
інтереси українського народу героїчного
народу який сьогодні бореться з
колаборантами зрадниками і з окупантами
і звичайно це так само велике питання до
силових структур відносно
відповідальності цих осіб які причетні
до колабораційних дій Артур Герасимов
детальніше розповість про новели нашу
законопроекту але ще раз наголошую що
мова стосується всіх заборонених партій
мова стосується припинення по суті
діяльності цих зрадників як в Верховній
Раді України так і в місцевих радах
шановні журналісти шановні українці
вже заборонені в Україні і опзж і партія
Вітренко і партія ширія
а
в Верховній Раді України це вищому
законодавчому органі країна яка воює і
б'ється з агресором
сидять колаборанти і не просто сидять а
вони навіть визнаються
діючою владою якнайкращі друзі чи
найкращі там колеги сприйняття законів
причому не дуже добрих законів для
держави це і стосується і закону коли
забирали гроші з армії перекидали на
дороги Подивіться хто голосував слуги та
колишнього ПСЖ це стосується і
законопроекту про мідія
який голосували слуги та колишнього ПСЖ
де вони хочуть поставити підтотальний як
в Росії контроль всіх електронних мідія
всіх веб-сайтів
сторінок в Фейсбуці Ну і так далі І так
далі і
велике питання Чому влада сьогодні
не хоче цих прибічників російського мира
прибирати не просто з політичного життя
країни а просто з нашою боротьби що
стосується закону то
передбачається внесення в зиму
узгоджених змін до низки законів України
там і Про статус народного депутата
України про статус депутатів місцевих
ряд рад багатьох інших і там будеш дуже
чітко прописано що заборона діяльності
політичної партії є підставою для
призупинення здійснення повноважень
обраного від такої політичної партії
народного депутата України а також для
дострокового припинення повноважень
депутатів місцевої ради які були обрані
від цієї партії
також дуже важливо що депутати будь-яких
рівнів від заборонених партій не зможуть
брати участь у засіданнях Верховної Ради
України це важливо тому що сьогодні на
жаль діюча Влада разом з семи
колаборантами приймає дуже недобрий
закони
Окрім цього вони не можуть вступати до
складу депутатських фракцій і груп тобто
не можна буде перевзуватися в повітрі а
також не можна бути отримувати
повноваження членів офіційних делегацій
Верховної Ради України новий Уявіть собі
люди їздили в Москву до російського
керівництва люди скрізь підтримували
Росію і навіть під час вторгнення а
сьогодні вони що будуть представляти
український парламент міжнародних
делегаціях де весь світ нас підтримує
це безпринципність
залишати такий стан речей і цей закон
для того щоб це виправити знаєте і пан
Медведчук і пан Деркач і парк Кузьмін і
пан Рабінович Вони досі народні депутати
і
це є неподобством коли Влада
використовує тих
хто заводив сюди російський мир
для того щоб боротися проти України
сьогодні воїни б'ються на фронті не для
того щоб тут була побудована маленька
Росія чи маленька Білорусь вони б'ються
за вільну демократичну Україну
і саме для того щоб запобігти
побудовіту тоталітарної Росії два чи
Білорусі 2 ми реєструємо цей
законопроект і наостанок
в тому що стосується референдумів Ми б
хотіли звернутися
до служби безпеки України а також до
всіх небайдужих
громадян і прихильників
збирати інформацію про діяльність
московських попів які приймали
найактивнішу участь в організації цих
фейкових референдумів зло має бути
покаране тому Служба безпеки України
займатися будь ласка тим що збирайте
Докази і передавайте до суду матеріали
на тих
хто
організовував ці фейкові реферат ми
разом з росіянами вони московських попів
бо це є державна зрада і збирати
матеріали і їх привлікати до
відповідальності треба саме за статтею
державного зрада бо це
було б організовано проти українського
северенітету проти нашої територіальної
цінності і проти України як держави
Дякую за увагу
Дякуємо колеги дійсно ми тільки
повернулися з Артура з Петром
олексійовичем Порошенком з нашою
командою з деокупованих селищ
Харківської області на всіх звільнених
територіях люди розповідали що Ну і це
не новина так було і на Київщині так
було на Чернігівщині на Сумщині окупанти
заходили зі списками з конкретними
списками про українських патріотів
членів проукраїнських патріотичних
партій воїнів АТО забирали їх родичів
катували вимагали інформацію про все це
і серед оцих колаборантів розрадників
були в першу чергу представники
колишньої регіонали в шарійці комуністи
теж заборонена партія да упсж Яке дали
найбільший цей відсоток зрадників і
Московський попи які в своїх церквах там
Наша команда вимагала прийняти закон про
колабораціонізм давно Але як ви знаєте
проголосували за нього вже коли війна
почалася і важливо не тільки прийняти
закон який там проголосовано було
конституційною більшості в парламенті
Важливо щоб він працював тому дійсно
Артур справедливо зазначив що наша
команда підготувала низку звернень до
служби безпеки України сподіваємося вони
вже а-а і внутрішньо там очистилися тому
що дуже серйозний був Указ Президента
Зеленського щодо звільнення попереднього
керівництва за фактом дії які призвели
до чисельних жертв так от Ми хочемо
почути і хочеться мого розслідування в
СБУ
встановлені ці факти про кого йдеться
про які жертви йдеться тому що дійсно на
багатьох звільнених територіях нам
розповідали люди що перше зникали знаєте
як роса на сонці
представники прокуратури СБУ там ще
когось силовики міліції поліції і люди
залишалися одні да дбр тікали там втил
глибокій І от зараз потрібно встановити
факти е-е колаборації факти зради Ну і
факти недбалься службово коли або
місцева Влада або силові структури
кидали все це напризволяще і наголошуємо
ще раз Шановні колеги народні депутати
від голосу батьківщини довіри за
майбутнього і слуги народу там теж є
люди які усвідомлюють ризики присутності
в парламенті партії які просували
московські наративи ми реєструємо
законопроект сьогодні до кінця доби
відкрита
долучення як співавтора до цього закону
І ми нагадаємо що під цим законопроектом
мають підписатися всі проукраїнські
патріотичні політики Верховної Ради
України а також ми розробляємо наступні
наші ініціативи щодо того що має бути
посилена відповідальність за
колабораціонізм і дорогі журналісти
Дорогі українці які пишуть наші партії
нам з Артуром дуже часто інформують про
те чи інші дії будь ласка давайте
інформацію про зрадників колаборантів Ну
а ми вже користуючись статусом народного
депутата будемо готувати відповідні
звернення запити до силових структур
Дякую за увагу До побачення зараз
зробимо
зроби нам фотографію нашу з Артуром